in a moment i'm going to tell you about
a certain really nice puzzle involving
the shadow of a cube
but before we get to that i should say
that the point of this video is not
exactly the puzzle per se it's about two
distinct problem-solving styles that are
reflected in two different ways that we
can tackle this problem in fact let's
anthropomorphize those two different
styles by imagining two students alice
and bob that embody each one of the
approaches
so bob will be the kind of student who
really loves calculation as soon as
there's a moment when he can dig into
the details and get a very concrete view
of the concrete situation in front of
him that's where he's the most pleased
alice on the other hand is more inclined
to procrastinate the computations not
because she doesn't know how to do them
or doesn't want to per se but she
prefers to get a nice high level general
overview of the kind of problem she's
dealing with the general shape that it
has before she digs into the
computations themselves
she's most pleased if she understands
not just the specific question sitting
in front of her but also the broadest
possible way that you could generalize
it and especially if the more general
view can lend itself to more swift and
elegant computations once she does
actually sit down to carry them out
now the puzzle that both of them are
going to be faced with is to find the
average area for the shadow of a cube
so if i have a cube kind of sitting here
hovering in space there are a few things
that influence the area of its shadow
one obvious one would be the size of the
cube smaller cube smaller shadow but
also if it's sitting at different
orientations those orientations
correspond to different particular
shadows with different areas and when i
say find the average here what i mean is
average over all possible orientations
for a particular size of the cube
the astute among you might point out
that it also matters a lot where the
light source is if the light source were
very low close to the cube itself then
the shadow ends up larger and if the
light source were kind of positioned
laterally off to the side this can
distort the shadow and give it a very
different shape
accounting for that light position
stands to be highly interesting in its
own right but the puzzle is hard enough
as it is so at least initially let's do
the easiest thing we can and say that
the light is directly above the cube and
really far away effectively infinitely
far so that all we're considering is a
flat projection in the sense that if you
look at any coordinates x y z in space
the flat projection would be x y zero
so just to get our bearings the easiest
situation to think about would be if the
cube is straight up with two of its
faces parallel to the ground in that
case this flat projection shadow is
simply a square and if we say the side
lengths of the cube are s then the area
of that shadow is s squared and by the
way anytime that i have a label up on
these animations like the one down here
i'll be assuming that the relevant cube
has a side length of one
now another special case among all the
orientations that's fun to think about
is if the long diagonal is parallel to
the direction of the light in that case
the shadow actually looks like a regular
hexagon and if you use some of the
methods that we will develop in a few
minutes you can compute that the area of
that shadow is exactly the square root
of three times the area of one of the
square faces
but of course more often the actual
shadow will be not so regular as a
square or a hexagon it's some harder to
think about shape based on some harder
to think about orientation for this cube
earlier i casually threw out this phrase
of averaging over all possible
orientations but you could rightly ask
what exactly is that supposed to mean
i think a lot of us have an intuitive
feel for what we want it to mean at
least in the sense of what experiment
would you do to verify it you might
imagine tossing this cube in the air
like a die freezing it at some arbitrary
point recording the area of the shadow
from that position and then repeating
if you do this many many times over and
over you can take the mean of your
sample
the number that we want to get at the
true average here should be whatever
that experimental mean approaches as you
do more and more tosses approaching
infinitely many
even still the sticklers among you could
complain that doesn't really answer the
question because it leaves open the
issue of how we're defining a random
toss
the proper way to answer this if we want
it to be more formal would be to first
describe the space of all possible
orientations which mathematicians have
actually given a fancy name they call it
so3 typically defined in terms of a
certain family of three by three
matrices and the question we want to
answer is what probability distribution
are we putting to this entire space it's
only when such a probability
distribution is well defined that we can
answer a question involving an average
if you are a stickler for that kind of
thing i want you to hold off on that
question until the end of the video
you'll be surprised at how far we can
get with the more heuristic experimental
idea of just repeating a bunch of random
tosses without really defining the
distribution
once we see alice and bob's solutions
it's actually very interesting to ask
how exactly each one of them defined
this distribution along their way
and remember this is not meant to be a
lesson about cube shadows per se but a
lesson about problem solving told
through the lens of two different
mindsets that we might bring to the
puzzle
and as with any lesson on problem
solving the goal here is not to get to
the answer as quickly as we can but
hopefully for you to feel like you found
the answer yourself so if ever there's a
point when you feel like you might have
an idea give yourself the freedom to
pause and try to think it through
as a first step and this is really
independent of any particular
problem-solving styles just anytime you
find a hard question a good thing that
you can do is ask what's the simplest
possible non-trivial variant of the
problem that you can try to solve
so in our case what you might say is
okay let's forget about averaging over
all the orientations that's a tricky
thing to think about and let's even
forget about all the different faces of
the cube because they overlap and that's
also tricky to think about just for one
particular face and one particular
orientation can we compute the area of
this shadow
once more if you want to get your
bearings with some special cases the
easiest is when that face is parallel to
the ground in which case the area of the
shadow is the same as the area of the
face and on the other hand if we were to
tilt that face 90 degrees then its
shadow will be a straight line and it
has an area of zero
so bob looks at this and he wants an
actual formula for that shadow and the
way he might think about it is to
consider the normal vector perpendicular
off of that face and what seems relevant
is the angle that that normal vector
makes with the vertical with the
direction where the light is coming from
which we might call theta
now from the two special cases we just
looked at we know that when theta is
equal to zero the area of that shadow is
the same as the area of the shape itself
which is s squared if the square has
side lengths s
and if theta is equal to 90 degrees then
the area of that shadow is zero and it's
probably not too hard to guess that
trigonometry will be somehow relevant so
anyone comfortable with their trig
functions could probably hazard a guess
as to what the right formula is but bob
is more detail-oriented than that he
wants to properly prove what that area
should be rather than just making a
guess based on the endpoints
and the way you might think about it
could be something like this if we
consider the plane that passes through
the vertical as well as our normal
vector and then we consider all the
different slices of our shape that are
in that plane or parallel to that plane
then we can focus our attention on a
two-dimensional variant of the problem
if we just look at one of those slices
who has a normal vector and angle theta
away from the vertical
its shadow might look something like
this
and if we draw a vertical line up to the
left here we have ourselves a right
triangle and from here we can do a
little bit of angle chasing where we
follow around what that angle theta
implies about the rest of the diagram
and this means the lower right angle in
this triangle is precisely theta
so when we want to understand the size
of this shadow in comparison to the
original size of the piece we can think
about the cosine of that angle theta
which remembers the adjacent over the
hypotenuse it's literally the ratio
between the size of the shadow and the
size of the slice
so the factor by which the slice gets
squished down in this direction is
exactly cosine of theta
and if we broaden our view to the entire
square all the slices in that direction
get scaled by the same factor but in the
other direction and the one
perpendicular to that slice there is no
stretching or squishing because the face
is not at all tilted in that direction
so overall the two-dimensional shadow of
our two-dimensional face should also be
scaled down by this factor of a cosine
of theta it lines up with what you might
intuitively guess given the case where
the angle is 0 degrees in the case where
it's 90 degrees but it's reassuring to
see why it's true
and actually as stated so far this is
not quite correct there is a small
problem with the formula that we've
written
in the case where theta is bigger than
90 degrees the cosine would actually
come out to be negative but of course we
don't want to consider the shadow to
have negative area at least not in a
problem like this
so there's two different ways you could
solve this you could say we only ever
want to consider the normal vector that
is pointing up that has a positive z
component
or more simply we could say just take
the absolute value of that cosine and
that gives us a valid formula
[Music]
so bob's happy because he has a precise
formula describing the area of the
shadow
but alice starts to think about it a
little bit differently she says okay
we've got some shape and then we apply a
rotation that sort of situates it into
3d space in some way and then we apply a
flat projection that shoves that back
into two-dimensional space and what
stands out to her is that both of these
are linear transformations that means
that in principle you could describe
each one of them with a matrix and that
the overall transformation would look
like the product of those two matrices
what alice knows from one of her
favorite subjects linear algebra is that
if you take some shape and you consider
its area then you apply some linear
transformation then the area of that
output looks like some constant times
the original area of the shape more
specifically we have a name for that
constant it's called the determinant of
the transformation
if you're not so comfortable with linear
algebra we could give a much more
intuitive description and say if you
uniformly stretch the original shape in
some direction the output will also
uniformly get stretched in some
direction so the area of each of them
should scale in proportion to each other
now in principle alice could compute
this determinant but it's not really her
style to do that at least not to do so
immediately instead the thing that she
writes down is how this proportionality
constant between our original shape and
its shadow does not depend on the
original shape we could be talking about
the shadow of this cat outline or
anything else and the size of it doesn't
really matter the only thing affecting
that proportionality constant is what
transformation we're applying which in
this context means we could write it
down as some factor that depends on the
rotation being applied to the shape
in the back of our mind because of bob's
calculation we know what that factor
looks like you know it's the absolute
value of the cosine of the angle between
the normal vector and the vertical but
alice right now is just saying yeah yeah
i can think about that eventually when i
want to but she knows we're about to
average over all the different
orientations anyway so she holds out
some hope that any specific formula
about a specific orientation might get
washed away in that average
now it's easy to look at this and say
okay well alice isn't really doing
anything then of course the area of the
shadow is proportional to the area of
the original shape they're both
two-dimensional quantities they should
both scale like two-dimensional things
but keep in mind this would not at all
be true if we were dealing with the
harder case that has a closer light
source in that case the projection is
not linear so for example if i rotate
this cat so that its tail ends up quite
close to the light source then if i
stretch the original shape uniformly in
the x direction say by a factor of 1.5
it might have a very disproportionate
effect on the ultimate shadow because
the tail gets very disproportionately
blown up as it gets really close to the
light
again alice is keeping an eye out for
what properties of the problem are
actually relevant because that helps her
know how much she can generalize things
does the fact that we're thinking about
a square face and not some other shape
matter no not really does the fact that
the transformation is linear matter yes
absolutely
[Music]
alice can also apply a similar way of
thinking about the average shadow for
any shape like this say we have some
sequence of rotations that we apply to
our square face and let's call them r1
r2 r3 and so on
then the area of the shadow in each one
of those cases looks like some factor
times the area of the square and that
factor depends on the rotation
so if we take an empirical average for
that shadow across the sample of
rotations we're looking at right now the
way it looks is to add up all of those
shadow areas and then divide by the
total number that we have
now because of the linearity this area
of the original square can cleanly
factor out of all of that and it ends up
on the left
this isn't the exact average that we're
looking for it's just an empirical mean
of a sample of rotations but in
principle what we're looking for is what
this approaches as the size of our
sample approaches infinity and all the
parts that depend on the size of the
sample sit cleanly away from the area
itself so whatever this approach is in
the limit it's just going to be some
number it might be a royal pain to
compute we're not sure about that yet
but the thing that alice notes is that
it's independent of the size and the
shape of the particular 2d thing that
we're looking at it's a universal
proportionality constant
and her hope is that that universality
somehow lends itself to a more elegant
way to deduce what it must be
now bob would be eager to compute this
constant here and now and in a few
minutes i'll show you how he does it but
before that i do want to stay in alice's
world for a little bit more because this
is where things start to really get fun
in her desire to understand the overall
structure of the question before diving
into the details she's curious now about
how the area of the shadow of the cube
relates to the area of its individual
faces now if we can say something about
the average area of a particular face
does that tell us anything about the
average area of the cube as a whole
for example a simple thing we could say
is that that area is definitely less
than the sum of the areas across all the
faces because there's a meaningful
amount of overlap between those shadows
but it's not entirely clear how to think
about that overlap because if we focus
our attention just on two particular
faces in some orientations they don't
overlap at all but in other orientations
they do have some overlap the specific
shape and area of that overlap seems a
little bit tricky to think about much
less how on earth we would average that
across all of the different orientations
but alice has about three clever
insights through this whole problem and
this is the first one of them she says
actually if we think about the whole
cube not just a pair of faces we can
conclude that the area of the shadow for
a given orientation is exactly one-half
the sum of the areas of all of the faces
intuitively you can maybe guess that
half of them are bathed in the light and
half of them are not but here's the way
that she justifies it she says for a
particular ray of light they would go
from the sky and eventually hit a point
in the shadow
that ray passes through the cube at
exactly two points there's one moment
when it enters and one moment when it
exits so every point in that shadow
corresponds to exactly two faces above
it
well okay that's not exactly true if
that beam of light happened to go
through the edge of one of the squares
there's a little bit of ambiguity on how
many faces it's passing but those
account for zero area inside the shadow
so we're safe to ignore them if the
thing we're trying to do is compute the
area
if alice is pressed and she needs to
justify why exactly this is true which
is important for understanding how the
problem might generalize she can appeal
to the idea of convexity convexity is
one of those properties where a lot of
us have an intuitive sense for what it
should mean you know it's shapes that
just bulge out they never dent inward
but mathematicians have a pretty clever
way of formalizing it that's helpful for
actual proofs
they say that a set is convex if the
line that connects any two points inside
that set is entirely contained within
the set itself
so a square is convex because no matter
where you put two points inside that
square the line connecting them is
entirely contained inside the square but
something like the symbol pi is not
convex i can easily find two different
points so that the line connecting them
has to peak outside of the set itself
none of the letters in the word convex
are themselves convex you can find two
points so that the line connecting them
has to pass outside of the set it's a
really clever way to formalize this idea
of a shape that only bulges out because
any time that it dents inward you can
find these counter-example lines for our
cube because it's convex between the
first point of entry and the last point
of exit it has to stay entirely inside
the cube by definition of convexity but
if we were dealing with some other
non-convex shape like a donut you could
find a ray of light that enters then
exits then enters and exits again so you
wouldn't have a clean two-to-one cover
from the shadows the shadows of all of
its different parts if you were to cover
this in a bunch of faces would not be
precisely two times the area of the
shadow itself
so that's the first key insight the face
shadows double cover the cube shadow and
the next one is a little bit more
symbolic so let's start things off by
abbreviating our notation a little to
make room on the screen
instead of writing the area of the
shadow of the cube i'm just going to
write s of the cube and similarly
instead of the area of the shadow of a
particular face i'm just going to write
s of f where that subscript j indicates
which face i'm talking about
but of course we should really be
talking about the shadow of a particular
rotation applied to the cube so i might
write this as s of some rotation applied
to the cube and likewise on the right
it's the area of the shadow of that same
rotation applied to a given one of the
faces with the more compact notation at
hand let's think about the average of
this shadow area across many different
rotations some sample of r1 r2 r3 and so
on
again that average just involves adding
up all of those shadow areas and then
dividing them by n
and in principle if we were to look at
this for larger and larger samples let n
approach infinity that would give us the
average area of the shadow of the cube
some of you might be thinking yes we
know this you've said this already but
it's beneficial to write it out so that
we can understand why it is that
expressing the shadow area for a
particular rotation of the cube as a sum
across all of its faces or one half
times that sum at least
why is that beneficial what is that
going to do for us
well let's just write it out where for
each one of these rotations of the cube
we could break down that shadow as a sum
across that same rotation applied across
all of the faces
and when it's written as a grid like
this we can get to alice's second
insight which is to shift the way that
we're thinking about the sum from going
row by row to instead going column by
column
for example if we focused our attention
just on the first column what it's
telling us is to add up the area of the
shadow of the first face across many
different orientations
so if we were to take that sum and
divide it by the size of our sample that
gives us an empirical average for the
area of the shadow of this face
so if we take larger and larger samples
letting that size go to infinity this
will approach the average shadow area
for a square
likewise the second column can be
thought of as telling us the average
area for the second face of the cube
which should of course be the same
number and same deal for any other
column it's telling us the average area
for a particular face so that gives us a
very different way of thinking about our
whole expression instead of saying add
up the areas of the cubes at all the
different orientations we could say just
add up the average shadows for the six
different faces and divide the total by
one half the term on the left here is
thinking about adding up rows first and
the term on the right is thinking about
adding up columns first
in short the average of the sum of the
face shadows is the same as the sum of
the average of the face shadows maybe
that swap seems simple maybe it doesn't
but i can tell you that there is
actually a little bit more than meets
the eye to the step that we just took
but we'll get to that later
and remember we know that the average
area for a particular face looks like
some universal proportionality constant
times the area of that face so if we're
adding this up across all the faces of
the cube we could think of this as
equaling some constant times the surface
area of the cube
and that's pretty interesting the
average area for the shadow of this cube
is going to be proportional to its
surface area
but at the same time you might complain
well alice is just pushing around a
bunch of symbols here because none of
this matters if we don't know what that
proportionality constant is
i mean it almost seems obvious like of
course the average shadow area should be
proportional to the surface area they're
both two dimensional quantities so they
should scale in lock step with each
other
i mean it's not obvious after all for a
closer light source it simply wouldn't
be true and also this business where we
added up the grid column by column
versus row by row is a little more
nuanced than it might look at first
there's a subtle hidden assumption
underlying all of this which carries a
special significance when we choose to
revisit the question of what probability
distribution is being taken across the
space of all orientations
but more than anything the reason that
it's not obvious is that the
significance of this result right here
is not merely that these two values are
proportional it's that an analogous fact
will hold true for any convex solids and
crucially the actual content of what
alice has built up so far is that it'll
be the same proportionality constant
across all of them
now if you really mull over that some of
you may be able to predict the way that
alice is able to finish things off from
here it's really delightful it's
honestly my main reason for covering
this topic but before we get into it i
think it's easy to under-appreciate her
result unless we dig into the details of
what it is that she manages to avoid
so let's take a moment to turn our
attention back into bob's world because
while alice has been doing all of this
he's been busy doing some computations
in fact what he's been working on is
finding exactly what alice has yet to
figure out which is how to take the
formula that he found for the area of a
square's shadow and taking the natural
next step of trying to find the average
of that square's shadow averaged over
all possible orientations
so the way bob starts if he's thinking
about all the different possible
orientations for this square is to ask
what are all the different normal
vectors that that square can have in all
these orientations because everything
about its shadow comes down to that
normal vector it's not too hard to see
that all those possible normal vectors
trace out the surface of a sphere if we
assume it's a unit normal vector it's a
sphere with radius one
and furthermore bob figures that each
point of the sphere should be just as
likely to occur as any other our
probabilities should be uniform in that
way there's no reason to prefer one
direction over another
but in the context of continuous
probabilities it's not very helpful to
talk about the likelihood of a
particular individual point because in
the uncountable infinity of points on
the sphere that would be zero and
unhelpful
so instead the more precise way to
phrase this uniformity would be to say
the probability that our normal vector
lands in any given patch of area on the
sphere should be proportional to that
area itself more specifically it should
equal the area of that little patch
divided by the total surface area of the
sphere if that's true no matter what
patch of area we're considering that's
what we mean by a uniform distribution
on the sphere
now to be clear points on the sphere are
not the same thing as orientations in 3d
space because even if you know what
normal vector the square is going to
have that leaves us with another degree
of freedom the square could be rotated
about that normal vector
but bob doesn't actually have to care
about that extra degree of freedom
because in all of those cases the area
of the shadow is the same it's only
dependent on the cosine of the angle
between that normal vector and the
vertical which is kind of neat all those
shadows are genuinely different shapes
they're not the same but the area of
each of them will be the same
what this means is that when bob wants
this average shadow area over all
possible orientations all he really
needs to know is the average value of
this absolute value of cosine of theta
for all different possible normal
vectors all different possible points on
the sphere so how do you compute an
average like this
well if we lived in some kind of
discrete pixelated world where there's
only a finite number of possible angles
theta that that normal vector could have
the average would be pretty
straightforward what you do is find the
probability of landing on any particular
value of theta which will tell us
something like how much of the sphere do
normal vectors with that angle make up
and then you multiply it by the thing we
want to take the average of this formula
for the area of the shadow
and then you would add that up over all
of the different possible values of
theta ranging from 0 up to 180 degrees
or pi radians
but of course in reality there is a
continuum of possible values of theta
this uncountable infinity and the
probability of landing on any specific
particular value of theta will actually
be zero and so a sum like this
unfortunately doesn't really make any
sense or if it does make sense adding up
infinitely many zeros should just give
us a zero
[Music]
the short answer for what we do instead
is that we compute an integral and i'll
level with you the hard part here is i'm
not entirely sure what background i
should be assuming from those of you
watching right now uh maybe it's the
case that you're quite comfortable with
calculus and you don't need me to
belabor the point here maybe it's the
case that you're not familiar with
calculus and i shouldn't just be
throwing down integrals like that or
maybe you you know you took a calculus
class a while ago but you need a little
bit of a refresher i'm gonna go with the
option of setting this up as if it's a
calculus lesson because to be honest
even when you are quite comfortable with
integrals setting them up can be kind of
an error-prone process and calling back
to the underlying definition is a good
way to sort of check yourself in the
process
if we lived in a time before calculus
existed and integrals weren't a thing
and we wanted to approximate an answer
to this question one way we could go
about it is to take a sample of values
for theta that ranges from 0 up to 180
degrees
we might think of them as evenly spaced
with some sort of difference between
each one some delta theta
and it's still the case that it would be
unhelpful to ask about the probability
of a particular value of theta occurring
even if it's one in our sample that
probability would still be zero and it
would be unhelpful but what is helpful
to ask is the probability of falling
between two different values from our
sample in this little band of latitude
with a width of delta theta
based on our assumption that the
distribution along the sphere should be
uniform that probability comes down to
knowing the area of this band more
specifically the chances that a randomly
chosen vector lands in that band should
be that area divided by the total
surface area of the sphere to figure out
that area let's first think of the
radius of that band which if the radius
of our sphere is one is definitely going
to be smaller than one
and in fact if we draw the appropriate
little right triangle here you can see
that that little radius let's just say
at the top of the band should be the
sine of our angle the sine of theta
this means that the circumference of the
band should be 2 pi times the sine of
that angle and then the area of the band
should be that circumference times its
thickness that little delta theta or
rather the area of our band is
approximately this quantity what's
important is that for a finer sample of
many more values of theta the accuracy
of that approximation would get better
and better
now remember the reason we wanted this
area is to know the probability of
falling into that band which is this
area divided by the surface area of the
sphere which we know to be 4 pi times
its radius squared
that's a value that you could also
compute with an integral similar to the
one that we're setting up now but for
now we can take it as a given as a
standard well-known formula
and this probability itself is just a
stepping stone in the direction of what
we actually want which is the average
area for the shadow of a square
to get that we'll multiply this
probability times the corresponding
shadow area which is this absolute value
of cosine theta expression we've seen
many times up to this point
and our estimate for this average would
now come down to adding up this
expression across all of the different
bands all of the different samples of
theta that we've taken
this right here by the way is when bob
is just totally in his element we've got
a lot of exact formulas describing
something very concrete actually digging
in on our way to a real answer
and again if it feels like a lot of
detail i want you to appreciate that
fact so that you can appreciate just how
magical it is when alice manages to
somehow avoid all of this
anyway looking back at our expression
let's clean things up a little bit like
factoring out all of the terms that
don't depend on theta itself
and we can simplify that 2 pi divided by
4 pi to simply be one half
and to make it a little more analogous
to calculus with integrals let me just
swap the main terms inside the sum here
what we now have this sum that's going
to approximate the answer to our
question is almost what an integral is
instead of writing the sigma for sum we
write the integral symbol this kind of
elongated leibnizian s showing us that
we're going from zero to pi
and instead of describing the step size
as delta theta a concrete finite amount
we instead describe it as d theta which
i like to think of as signaling the fact
that some kind of limit is being taken
what that integral means by definition
is whatever the sum on the bottom
approaches for finer and finer
subdivisions more dense samples that we
might take for theta itself
and at this point for those of you who
do know calculus i'll just write down
the details of how you would actually
carry this out as you might see it
written down in bob's notebook
it's the usual anti-derivative stuff but
the one key step is to bring in a
certain trig identity
in the end what bob finds after doing
this is the surprisingly clean fact that
the average area for a square's shadow
is precisely one-half the area of that
square
this is the mystery constant which alice
doesn't yet know
if bob were to look over her shoulder
and see the work that she's done he
could finish out the problem right now
he plugs in the constant that he just
found and he knows the final answer
and now finally with all of this as
backdrop what is it that alice does to
carry out the final solution i
introduced her as someone who really
likes to generalize the results she
finds and usually those generalizations
end up as interesting footnotes that
aren't really material for solving
particular problems but this is a case
where the generalization itself draws
her to a quantitative result remember
the substance of what she's found so far
is that if you look at any convex solid
then the average area for its shadow is
going to be proportional to its surface
area and critically it'll be the same
proportionality constant across all of
these solids so all alice needs to do is
find just a single convex solid out
there where she already knows the
average area of its shadow
and some of you may see where this is
going the most symmetric solid available
to us is a sphere
no matter what the orientation of that
sphere its shadow the flat projection
shadow is always a circle with an area
of pi r squared
so in particular that's its average
shadow area
and the surface area of a sphere like i
mentioned before is exactly 4 pi r
squared
by the way i did make a video talking
all about that surface area formula and
how archimedes proved it thousands of
years before calculus existed so you
don't need integrals to find it
the magic of what alice has done is that
she can take this seemingly specific
fact that the shadow of a sphere has an
area exactly one-fourth its surface area
and use it to conclude a much more
general fact that for any convex solid
out there its shadow and surface area
are related in the same way in a certain
sense
so with that she can go and fill in the
details of the particular question about
a cube and say that its average shadow
area will be one-fourth times its
surface area 6s squared
but the much more memorable fact that
you'll go to sleep thinking about is how
it didn't really matter that we were
talking about a cube at all
now that's all very pretty but some of
you might complain that this isn't
really a valid argument because spheres
don't have flat faces when i said
alice's argument generalizes to any
convex solid if we actually look at the
argument itself it definitely depends on
the use of a finite number of flat faces
for example if we were mapping it to a
dodecahedron you would start by saying
that the area of a particular shadow of
that dodokahedron looks like exactly one
half times the sum of the areas of the
shadows of all its faces once again you
could use a certain ray of light mixed
with convexity argument to draw that
conclusion
and remember the benefit of expressing
that shadow area as a sum
is that when we want to average over a
bunch of different rotations we can
describe that sum as a big grid where we
can then go column by column and
consider the average area for the shadow
of each face
and also a critical fact was the
conclusion from much earlier that the
average shadow for any 2d object a flat
2d object which is important will equal
some universal proportionality constant
times its area the significance was that
that constant didn't depend on the shape
itself it could have been a square or a
cat or the pentagonal faces of our
dodecahedron whatever
so after hastily carrying this over to a
sphere that doesn't have a finite number
of flat faces you would be right to
complain but luckily it's a pretty easy
detail to fill in what you can do is
imagine a sequence of different
polyhedra that successively approximate
a sphere in the sense that their faces
hug tighter and tighter around the
genuine surface of the sphere
for each one of those approximations we
can draw the same conclusion that its
average shadow is going to be
proportional to its surface area with
this universal proportionality constant
so then if we say okay let's take the
limit of the ratio between the average
shadow area at each step and the surface
area at each step well since that ratio
is never changing it's always equal to
this constant then in the limit it's
also going to equal that constant but on
the other hand by their definition in
the limit their average shadow area
should be that of a circle which is pi r
squared and the limit of the surface
areas would be the surface area of the
sphere 4 pi r squared so we do genuinely
get the conclusion that intuition would
suggest but as is so common with alice's
argument here we do have to be a little
delicate in how we justify that
intuition
it's easy for this contrast of alice and
bob to come across like a value judgment
as if i'm saying look how clever alice
has managed to be she insightfully
avoided all those computations that bob
had to do
but that would be a very um
misguided conclusion
i think there's an important way that
popularizations of math differ from the
feeling of actually doing math there's
this bias towards showing the slick
proofs the arguments with some clever
keen insight that lets you avoid doing
calculations
i could just be projecting since i'm
very guilty of this but what i can tell
you sitting on the other side of the
screen here is that it feels a lot more
attractive to make a video about alice's
approach than bob's for one thing in
alice's approach the line of reasoning
is fun it has these nice aha moments but
also crucially the way that you explain
it is more or less the same for a very
wide range of mathematical backgrounds
it's much less enticing to do a video
about bob's approach not because the
computations are all that bad i mean
they're honestly not but the pragmatic
reality is that the appropriate pace to
explain it looks very different
depending on the different mathematical
backgrounds in the audience
so you watching this right now clearly
consume math videos online and i think
in doing so it's worth being aware of
this bias if the aim is to have a
genuine lesson on problem solving too
much focus on the slick proofs runs the
risk of being disingenuous
for example let's say we were to step up
to challenge mode here and ask about the
case with a closer light source to my
knowledge there is not a similarly slick
solution to alice's here where you can
just relate to a single shape like a
sphere
the much more productive warm-up to have
done would have been the calculus of
bob's approach
and if you look at the history of this
problem it was proved by koshi in 1832
and if we paw through his handwritten
notes they look a lot more similar to
bob's work than alice's work right here
at the top of page 11 you can see what
is essentially the same integral that
you and i set up in the middle
on the other hand the whole framing of
the paper is to find a general fact not
something specific like the case of a
cube so if we were asking the question
which of these two mindsets correlates
with the act of discovering new math the
right answer would almost certainly have
to be a blend of both
but i would suggest that many people
don't sign enough weight to the part of
that blend where you're eager to dive
into calculations i think there's some
risk that the videos i make might
contribute to that
in the podcast that i did with the
mathematician alex kontorovich he talked
about the often underappreciated
importance of just drilling on
computations to build intuition whether
you're a student engaging with a new
class or a practicing research
mathematician engaging with a new field
of study
a listener actually wrote in to
highlight what an impression that
particular section made they're a phd
student and described themselves as
being worried that their mathematical
abilities were starting to fade which
they attributed to becoming older and
less sharp but hearing a practicing
mathematician talk about the importance
of doing hundreds of concrete examples
in order to learn something new
evidently that changed their perspective
in their own words recognizing this
completely reshaped their outlook and
their results
and if you look at the famous
mathematicians through history you know
newton euler gauss all of them they all
have this seemingly infinite patience
for doing tedious calculations
the irony of being biased to show
insights that let us avoid calculations
is that the way people often train up
the intuitions to find those insights in
the first place is by doing piles and
piles of calculations
all that said something would definitely
be missing without the alice mindset
here i mean think about it how sad would
it be if we solved this problem for a
cube and we never stepped outside of the
trees to see the forest and understand
that this is a super general fact it
applies to a huge family of shapes
and if you consider that math is not
just about answering the questions that
are posed to you but about introducing
new ideas and constructs one fun side
note about alice's approach here is that
it suggests a fun way to quantify the
idea of convexity rather than just
having a yes no answer is it convex is
it not we could put a number to it by
saying consider the average area of the
shadow of some solid multiply that by
four divided by the surface area and if
that number is one you've got a convex
solid but if it's less than one it's
non-convex and how close it is to one
tells you how close it is to being
convex
also one of the nice things about the
alice solution here is that it helps
explain why it is that mathematicians
have what can sometimes look like a
bizarre infatuation with generality and
with abstraction the more examples that
you see where generalizing and
abstracting actually helps you to solve
a specific case well the more you start
to adopt the same infatuation
and as a final thought for the stalwart
viewers among you who've stuck through
it this far
there is still one unanswered question
about the very premise of our puzzle
what exactly does it mean to choose a
random orientation now if that feels
like a silly question like of course we
know what it should mean i would
encourage you to watch a video that i
just did with numberphile on a conundrum
from probability known as bertrand's
paradox
after you watch it and if you appreciate
some of the nuance at play here homework
for you is to reflect on where exactly
alice and bob implicitly answered this
question
the case with bob is relatively
straightforward but the point at which
alice locks down some specific
distribution on the space of all
orientations well it's not at all
obvious it's actually very subtle
[Music]
you